(intro music)
Hello I'm The Nostalgia Critic, I remember it so you don't have to
There has been a war going on for years
It caused bloodshit anarchy chaos it's torn this world apart
When you meet someone for the first time
An immediate screaming is needed that can only be summed up in one question
And one question only
"Tangled (2010) or Frozen (2013)?"
Strange to think but there's a kind of rivalry
among movie fans about which one is better
Disney's version of Rapunzel or Disney's version of the snowqueen?
It's similar to the rivalry you will see among Geeks,
sports fans
and girl's doomed to disappointment
but I was kinda shock to discover the more
and more I talk to people
the more they seemed to really want to pick a side
If you say you like Frozen, there's always someone that says
Oh! But Tangled is so much better
If you say you like Tangled,
there's always someone that say Oh! What's the point when you have Frozen?!
So why on earth is there such a debate?
I mean nobody is comparing Lion King to Aladdin?
or The Little Mermaid against Beauty and the Beast?
Well, maybe one of the reason is there does seemed to be a lot of similarities.
Both films does seemed to be focus on CGI princesses
Who all ready look pretty similar.
Whom optimisticall perky, having issues with the magical problem
, come across a chiseled man whom teaches them the ways of the outside world.
stumbled across a comedy sidekick,
and goes back and forth on saving each other
while trying to resolve their problem
Why would there be an issue with these differences when they seemed so much alike?
Well, like anything there's gonna be some elements that
that are done better than others
one that most peole can agree with is the story(Tangled)
Even people who loved Frozen acknowledge
the story is not the strongest part
ESPECIALLY the backstory.
There's curses and trolls and wiping out memories,
and parents making downright psychotic decisions.
It doesn't make a whole lot of sense.
Tangled, like most people can agree has a very flowing narrative.
It's a good update to the classic fairy tales that's easy to follow and easy to relate to.
I would make the argument that the comic relief is a little better too.
Not that either film rely on just one element for their comedy THANK GOD!
But there certainly are chracters created mostly to get a laugh.
Where the one in Frozen is fine but kinda typical.
The one in Tangled stands out much much more!!!(Maximus)
How many times have you seen a horse act like Tom Lee Jones from The Fugitive?
It's such a bizzare idea
but their conviction to it completely sells us on it
resulting in a ton of laughs.
But, Tangled has some weaknesses too,
the villain for example seems to go back and forth between trying to be menancing
and trying to be a silly obstacle.
While other Disney villains balance comical and threatening very well,
this one seems to be half the energy at both,
which makes a little harder to get invested in her.
Not to say the villain in Frozen was perfect,
but it was meant to be a surprise
which help further the message of the film.
And when the reveal is shown, he was surprisingly kind of intimidating.
Also, the music while good,
is still not as hummable as Frozen's.
Even with a similar sound, the music to Frozen is a monster!
Taking basic establishing songs we've heard variations of for years
and using it to once again tell the story and explain how a person feels.
But on top of that, they're just more memorable.
Hell, even TOO memorable!
There's sing-along that are still all over the place!
And there's still kids everywhere that will not stop humming these songs.
So yeah! Both seemed to have strengths, both seemed to have weaknesses.
But why do so many people demand that they choose which one they like better?
Perhaps a big part of it is
that they do such a good job at the parts that people like to compare.
I mean okay, there's details we can contrast
like environment, timing, style and so forth.
But the parts people usually like most in a movie are the characters and the ideas.
As mentioned before, these characters and ideas are so similar,
it's almost impossible not to naturally
want to compare them
Anna has been sheltered most of her life just like Rapunzel,
resulting in a naive but giddily cheerful protaganist.
Flynn and Christoff had spent most of their lives in the wild,
growing cynical but still a charmingly upbeat personality.
And both of them make fun of the popular  Disney tropes that have been popular for years
while also continuing others to still make it profitable.
For example, Flynn asks why the heck everybody suddenly burst into song.
I don't know if a Disney character has ever done that before.
Rapunzel is also physically more active than most disney princesses.
And I know a lot of you may think of Mulan
seeing how she was not a princess, Oh Yeah!
Don't believe your lies! k
Next issue, Frozen is  even more obvious with their dig at the  Disney tropes.
Hammering in that you can't just marry a guy you just met.
Now, I think most people grow up figuring this out for their own
but Disney still gets a lot of blame for instilling this mindset.
Even though, I have to meet a person who actually has this mindset.
I said person, that's a nuisance(Hyper Fan Girl).
But it's still a Disney product and they obviously are not going to abandon all their cash cows.
So the people are still gorgeous with the traditional big eyed look.
There's still elegant outfits and hairstyles we can parade into toys to sell.
And there's still the message of following your dreams and things will turn out how you want.
We can mock these all we want but there's no debating that this is what most kids like to see and thus,
most adults and their child want to see.
So it has the adult interest for something new, and the childhood with something familiar and nostalgic.
However, poularity wise, there's no contest,
Frozen is still everywhere!
Tangled, while a hit at the box office, is now where near the numbers that Frozen pulled in.
Which leads to the last and more likely reason why there's a rivalry,
when one gets more attention than the other.
Everyone seems to be praising Frozen as a masterpiece.
But when a film which looks and acts very similar comes out first,
It doesn't seem very fair.
If one film did these elements first and in some people's eyes, better,
Why isn't this everywhere as much as the other one?
Again, Tangled is definitely know, but no where near as big as Frozen.
There's even been a backlash that's been forming around it
of people saying it's a downright terrible movie!
I've done that tutorial about this before about whether or not hype can kill a film
and in some ways, the popularity of Frozen has drawn many people away from it.
calling it a bad movie.
We've seen this happened with lots of films like My Big Fat Greek Wedding,
The Dark Knight,
and most recently, Star Wars.
These are all movies that peole would like fine if they saw them on their own
But when combined with everyone saying It's amazing! It's one of the greatest things ever,
can easily arouse someone the wrong way.
It's hard to say Frozen is a terrible movie with so many actual terrible movies out there
But it's not hard to see someone not liking  it.
People like and dislike things for various reasons,
but in situations like this, it's much more appealing to root for the underdog.
The hipster argument, I like the original blank(___) before the new blank(___).
I saw what was perfect before society went and screwed it all up.
Not that this argument can't be true sometimes, heck a lot of the times.
But it seems to be one we like to fall back on a little too easily.
there are lots of times where a predecessor is better,
but people's acceptance or non-acceptance of it shouldn't make a difference,
whether you like a newer film or an older film doesn't automatically place you in a certain category.
The reason someone likes Tangled over Frozen could be entirely different from why you like Tangled over Frozen.
It's fun to share likes and what you have in common, but
acting like that suddenly makes you one of them or one of us
is just plain silly.
it's not what you like or what you don't like that makes you interesting,
it's why you like or don't like those things
and there's no right or wrong answer.
Comparing thoughs and opinions isn't done to judge or separate
at least, it shouldn't be.
It's done to understand and connect.
Both Frozen and Tangled can be good films.
And if you like one better the other, AWESOME!
Sure why?!
Maybe we will find out something about you we never knew before.
There will be similar arguments with similar franchises and there'll no doubt be a lot of fun to talk about.
But just remember, it is for fun.
We can learn a lot from it but don't ever take it too seriously.
Because whether it will be comparing ourselves,
or CGI princesses,
chances are, there's a lot more in common than you would think.(peaceful music~)
And besides, Frozen is better.
BOO!
I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy(aka that guy with the glasses)I'll remember it so you don't have to!
*double middle fingers*
BOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!
(outro song)
Hey everybody, Doug Walker here!
(is that Nostalgia Critic?)
Doing the charity shoutout and this week, we are doing the Children's Miracle Network.
This charity raises funds and awareness
for 170 hospitals that provide 32 million treatments each year to kids across the United States and Canada.
Now the donations stay local the fund critical treatments and health care services as well as
pediatric medical equipment and charitable care since 1983 this organization has raised
4.7 Billion dollars. Most of it just coming from one dollar donations
It's various fundraising partners and program support the nonprofit's mission
to save and improve the lives of as many children as possible.
One of those partners you might have heard of before Extra Life(extra-life.org)
uniting thousands of players around the world in a 24 hour gaming marathon to support this wonderful charity
since 2008 extra.org has raised over 14 million dollars for these hospitals.
You can see they do a lot of work and if you go to their Youtube channel you can also see
all the wonderful stories that they share, they have good people, good partnerships,
so definitely go check them out and make a huge difference in a child's life.